vigil held tonight to honor two girls
whose lives were suddenly taken victoria
salazar and sophia molina both died this
week they were each just 12 years old
and now the school that they attended is
coming together to remember them and
help those who love them most sacha
loftis was there tonight sasha joined us
in studio tonight now with more yes
denise and brian the grief felt here
tonight was really overwhelming as the
families and friends of two girls
honored them while their deaths were
unrelated they were equally as
devastating
sophia molina
and victoria salazar
who both were taken away from us these
past couple of days a community in
mourning after two young lives were
stolen before they could truly start
sophia molina who police say was shot
and killed by her father sunday and
victoria salazar who her family says
died of cancer were both honored at
somerset academy lone mountain on friday
she decided that her fight was not only
for her own life
but she also wanted to bring awareness
family friends and those in the
community gathered to share memories and
understand the weight of their grief
with a moment of silence a candlelit
vigil and an opportunity to leave
messages of support death is not
extinguishing these candles or the light
the light of sophia or victoria and
while the weight of this grief still
hangs heavy over everyone here
they hope to hold on to the memories
they have sophia
we love you and we will always have you
in our hearts as they try to move
forward
without those they love your memories
will stay forever in our minds
and in our hearts
both families have gofundmes online to
help with funeral expenses for both
girls we have a link to those on our
website eight newsnow dot com denise